the standard really has dropped though
of course it has I don't think so I
think women have higher standards than
ever no they have average men used to be
able to get average women they can't
anymore where it's it's for a small
percentage of men sure standards have
dropped it but for every other man's
standards are definitely higher I think
I think women's expectations of Ohio but
their standards have dropped so the
expectations of what they want is for
themselves yeah but they don't they
don't settle 50 they're predicting that
50 of women will be single and childless
between the ages of 25 and 45. no they
don't settle off the chat and Tyrone
because they get mad so they don't
understand what the level is so that's
so but it's because the expectations are
so high if they actually was more
realistic about it they'll get better
results as long as you keep one in the
same as long as 100 of women keep one of
the 20 20 of guys you're gonna still be
getting the bad results because it's the
expectations versus actually what your
real reality is right